[music]
Hello everyone and thank you for joining
us at Machina today. Uh my name is Z
Carot. I lead our frontier technology
division here at Metric Search. We are a
private equitybacked recruitment
organization and for the last seven
years I've recruited into the physical
AI sector and I'm pleased to be leading
this panel today on the topic of
hardware and is hardware a commodity now
and if so where does the value truly
lie? I'm joined on stage by an
exceptional panel spanning core robotic
building blocks and I'll let Cecil
introduce herself firstly.
>> Hi everybody. I'm Cecil Schwarver,
co-founder and CEO of Stereo Labs. So we
we make cameras and AI vision for
robots.
>> John.
>> Hi everyone. Great to be here. My name
is John Corentis. Uh I lead a go to
market activities in the physical AI
business unit at ARM.
>> My name is Robert. I'm one of the
co-founders and chief robotics officer
at Dexterity. We build logistics and
physical AI for or physical AI for
logistics and warehousing. Now, some of
our key products are in things like
truck loading, truck unloading,
palletizing, depalitizing, and so on.
>> Hello, my name is Rob Knights. I'm chief
robotics officer and co-founder at UMA,
where we are trying to make the world a
better place with robots for everyone.
>> It's great for everyone to be here. Um I
think the key talking point here today
on this topic is that whilst certain
components within hardware are becoming
increasingly commoditized core robotics
building blocks still remain highly
specialized and are far from commodity.
I'll pose a high level question to the
panel here to each of you firstly and
that question is Cecile firstly in your
opinion what components are not yet a
commodity?
Um, of course I come from the the
camera, you know, u ecosystem. So
definitely I'm I'm I'm I've been working
on cameras for 15 years trying to
replicate how we as human perceive the
world. And I can tell you we we haven't,
you know, reached the the level of
accuracy that we have. So there's uh a
long way ahead of us uh before we reach
the performance and the quality that we
need for a perfect replica of the of the
physical world. So yeah, definitely
cameras are not, you know, commoditized
yet.
>> John, what's your opinion on that?
>> Tikki, probably not uh going to surprise
you that I'm going to say compute,
right?
Um but, you know, if you think about the
world of autonomous robots, right? We we
we look at two particular areas of of
compute that are really really complex.
Uh one is what we call perception driven
intelligence. So that's a robot's
ability to understand where it is in in
the physical world and navigate through
that environment accordingly. Right? Uh
and the second area is what we call
interactive driven intelligence. Um so
looking at the the human robot interface
um primarily going to be voice in most
in in most scenarios and that voice
interaction requires a lot of contextual
awareness. It probably requires
understanding of sentiment. um it has uh
you know quite a high level of reasoning
capability attached to it. So if you
think of those two areas
perception-driven intelligence and
interactive driven intelligence you know
they are really really complex compute
problems we're really scratching the
surface of how to apply those
effectively into autonomous robotics
platforms. So those two areas
particularly in the in the in the
overall sense of compute I'd say are a
long way from being commoditized.
>> Thank you. And we'll we'll delve into
each of these topics in more detail, but
we've got the full stack guys over
there. So, Robert, you first. Where do
you see the where where's hardware not a
commodity right now?
>> Yeah, I'll give a twofold answer. The
first one I was just going to say is
cameras in compute. uh unsurprisingly
and
truly the the difficulties are in
thermals in size. Uh running these
robots out in the field, you don't
really have cloud connectivity. Um you
want data to be transferred from your
imaging sensors. We've got a dozen or so
running 10 plus gigabits per camera. Uh
it is a lot of data to transform and
then create action out of. And so having
the right uh physical interface to bring
in that data and then having unified
memory and strong um floatingpoint
operations to run models or even an LLM
on board is highly critical and is the
next step for us. Uh and this has been a
huge problem uh over the last several
years. And I think the other aspect for
us is going to be in hands and grippers.
It's still very up in the air. What's
the right answer? But also the
reliability and resilience and
robustness of these gripping
technologies is very important. You
can't be replacing things in the field
every two or 3 weeks.
>> Uh yes, indeed. Hands uh remain a
serious challenge. In terms of the
bodies themselves, I think we're quite
near to a low-level commodity with QDD
drives. It's not that hard anymore to
buy them off the shelf. You can get
parts machined online. You can just mail
order of them. They turn up. You can
screw them together. You can run Isaac
SIM. And testament to that is the
hundreds and hundreds of companies that
are now producing humanoids and they're
walking around and doing stuff. Hands
magnify all of those problems. We don't
really know what the answers are. We
don't really even know what the
questions are. And everything is smaller
and more compact.
On top of that, tactile sensing, what
you do with it, what formats we should
use. That's still a serious way to go
and it's going to become a major
bottleneck at some point. At the moment,
that's not what's stopping everything
advancing, but there will come a point,
I think, where that will really be what
holds it back.
Interesting. And humanoid hands and find
extras manipulation is something that
we'll definitely delve in on in more
detail later on in the panel. I think
one of the talking points I wanted to
discuss with you two in particular being
full stack roboticists uh at Dexterity
and at UMA is with regards to hardware
and software being defined and
constrained by each other. you know,
well-designed hardware can augment or
reduce the burden on an AI model or on
software. So, I'll start with you,
Robert. What are the what design
decisions have you made on the hardware
side to improve AI model performance on
your deployments there at Dexterity?
>> Yeah, that's a good question. So, a
couple points. Let's just take one of
our leading applications, truckloading,
for example. Humans were never really
meant to be working on these types of
very difficult tasks. And in fact, a lot
of the labor that we're trying to uh
augment and and potentially replace with
automation is things that weren't ever
meant for humans. And you'll realize a
lot of the ergonomic difficulties that
humans have, robots and especially
humanoid robots also have. And we've had
the need to increase the dextrous
capability of robots significantly. both
their strength, their ability to bend
and be flexible in tight environments
and get through things um and as well as
move extremely fast. And so if you look
at our robot system, we call it the
mech. They're 8 degrees of freedom per
arm. There are two arms and they're
fairly strong with 30 kg of payload, 5.4
meters of reach and they can still work
collaboratively and cooperatively in a
tight environment like a small shipping
container. And this is really difficult.
And we have experimented with a lot of
off-the-shelf stuff over the years and
the models, the planners, the
algorithms, they really struggle when
you don't have the right hardware. And
so I think the the key thing that you
have to realize is there's a bar for
feasibility and then there's a bar for
what I call superhuman effort,
superhuman ability. And that's what
makes customers and the actual
application um powerful and customers
willing to actually use your robots. And
so it really takes another level of
hardware innovation, kind of looking
back at your models, what's not working,
what's slowing down, and then perfecting
the hardware so that your models can
perform even better. And so I think the
shape of the robot, the strength of the
robot is highly critical um in a lot of
a lot of different applications. And um
you can actually share a lot of that
technology in a set of applications, but
I don't think there's one form factor
that's good for all applications.
>> That's interesting. the need for
superhuman performance, not just human
performance, but going above and beyond
that to improve efficiency. I'll ask the
same question to you, Rob. Obviously,
you've been designing hardware now for
for 25 years. So, what have you seen in
terms of hardware advancements improving
model performance?
>> Um, the advent of uh QDD drives and the
MIT mode um helped a lot with smoothing
out that whole process. Um you're seeing
uh technology that came across from
drones much higher power densities um
lower costs um but going even deeper
into the component level when you talk
to the manufacturers it takes a certain
amount of investment to get the volumes
up to bring down the cost of some
solution and they themselves are waiting
to see which solution will work the
best. So you have an interaction there
as well. Um, I'm a big fan of tendon
driven hands and it's still a very open
question for me how you can control
those with some of these techniques.
Most of the similreal approaches which
work so well for walking, they have a
simplified approach and when you try and
actually convert that into a more
complicated mechanical system that
causes a lot of issues. Um,
>> sorry not quite what the question was
again. it was about novel, you know,
electromechanical designs and how that
improves or augments model performance.
So, I think you've covered that there.
>> Yeah. No, definitely. So, for the for
the larger body where you're looking at
the larger joints, the QDDs have made a
huge difference on that. Um, but when
you come across to the hands, it um has
a lot of problems with heating and it
doesn't transfer as well. So, for the
large actions and the kind of hyper
beyond human performance, machines can
be better for that. But for the fine
dextrous tasks, that's still an open
question.
>> So it seems that there's still a long
way to go in kind of the hardware side
of things, whether that's dextrous hands
or whether that's novel form factors to
improve improve the kind of actual
performance of the robotic platform. So
in that sense, if it's still playing
such an important role in improving
performance or differentiating the
product, it cannot be said that hardware
is a commodity right now. Um I'd like to
move on into the sense that robot
performance is not just achieved by
system design choices but also kind of
subsystem level at the compute and at
the sensing level. Um John a question
for you and ARM would be how critical
are advanced CPUs for modern robotics?
Yes, super critical actually. If you
think about um you know in in in the
world of physical AI probably the key
metric to care about is the latency
between sensing and actuation right and
the systems that that that bridge that
capability are actually you know they're
multiple systems and and there's quite a
lot of complexity in there and you know
that that uh sensing to actuation needs
to happen in milliseconds. it needs to
happen in a reliable way. Um have some
degree of determinism. Um have safety
and security applied to it. And so um
you know if you think about you know
this the systems that are involved in in
bringing all of that together you know
require high levels of real time
performance uh require very efficient AI
execution of of AI workloads and require
functional safety and security all to
come together. Um and at the heart of
all of that are CPUs. They're
orchestrating all of those systems and
they're present in all of the systems
across across the robot that that that
performs all of those tasks from sensors
to actuators to the main brain. So I'd
say yeah CPU is critical in the
orchestration of all of that system
capability. And
>> I want to draw a parallel between the
autonomous driving world where maybe
they're a couple of years ahead of
robotics and humanoids in particular.
What we've witnessed in the AV industry
is the AV companies co-designing silicon
to meet the design constraints in their
work in their realm. Do you expect the
robotics industry to follow suit?
>> Um we we expect a blend um you know in
the same way that we see in the uh
autonomous vehicle industry. uh
companies will make decisions based off
of primarily you know the key things
that are driving those decisions are
what's the use case that they're really
focused on the application that they're
really focused on um what are the kind
of volumes that they that they have to
play with and what does that mean in
terms of the business case that that
that they have and so they're the
they're the kind of the four
fundamentals that drive the decision
whether to do you know in-house
vertically integrated silicon or whether
to take off the shelf um you know some
companies will take off the shelf
um uh available silicon because that
will be the fastest path to market.
There's a time to market advantage of
doing that. Um others will want to go
fully vertically integrated and design
their own silicon um so that they can
optimize for a specific workload. You
know, talk about software hardware, you
know, co code co-design at a hardware
level. you know, in some instances that
that will that that will really help and
and but it's a very kind of individual
choice for for for each of the companies
whether they go off the shelf or or or
invest in building their own silicon
teams and uh and bringing their own
silicon to market. Um, fundamentally
tying all of those things together is
the need for very efficient compute, uh,
safe compute, secure compute, and that
has to be done whether you buy off the
shelf or or or inhouse and, you know,
needs to be capable of kind of scaling
and expanding to a growing world of, you
know, high performance AI workloads that
need to be executed on those platforms.
Um, so whether you know regardless of
the decision you're making, you have to
have that as your key consideration is
how you going to be able to really
efficiently run those workloads. And
those workloads are going to be, you
know, potentially your individual uh
workloads for for a particular company.
Um, regardless of which way you go, you
know, ARM has an ecosystem of 22 million
software developers, right? Building
software around ARM. and and so you know
whether you're building in-house silicon
or taking you know ARMbased silicon off
the shelf there's already you know a
full suite of optimized software tools
AI frameworks that already highly
optimized to to be deployed for
development and deployment on on our
base system. So regardless which way you
go you got a huge ecosystem ready and
waiting to to deploy onto your platform.
>> Thank you for that. And then moving on
to the the sensing side again I think
advanced sensing is going to be a key
robotic building block in unlocking
advanced performance. Cecile that is
what stereo labs are doing. You know
you're developing a sensing and
perception platform for physical AI.
What role do you see in advanced sensing
for improving robotic performance and
deployment?
>> Yeah it's it's a very exciting time I
have to say. So we started this company
15 years ago. So we we we've seen the
early stage of robotics and the
evolution that we've seen during the for
the past couple of months is uh
incredible. We have there are so many
companies you know popping up popping up
every day with new ideas and new
approaches
um
different types of use cases. Uh for us
of course at the core uh there is vision
and perception because the obviously the
machine needs to see and understand the
world around the machine. So we have
been focusing on this for years and um I
forgot the question Z. [laughter]
>> It was regarding advanced sensing and
what improvements do we need to see?
>> Yeah, exactly. So we have been working
on this uh for years. So the the
objective is to have the exact replica
of the physical world and uh so we not
only sell cameras but we provide the
software. So it's a hardware and
software uh combination where we focus
on of course latency because this is
very important uh resolution um frame
rate [snorts] the depths accuracy
localization
uh uncertainty estimation. So those are
all the things that we are focusing on
at the moment because and this is why we
call it advanced because if you you can
take two cameras that share the same
SIMOS sensors but they can perform
dramatically different and uh this is
what we're focusing on and as you said
like safing safety is becoming crucial
especially in some application. So there
is a whole new world uh for robotics uh
and it needs to reach this level of
accuracy and safety that is that is hard
to reach today. So there's a there's a
lot of work and uh and this is what
we're doing today with uh so the company
we we've fused with ouster beginning of
the the year. So they they are building
lighters they have been building
lighters for a long time. So combining
both was really important for us because
we have customers who come to us and say
oh what vision or perception system
should I use and it's always the
customer always makes the decision and
and they're not perception engineers or
and we have been doing this for years.
So our idea with Angus the CEO of Aster
was to say hey come to us and we'll find
the best solution for your application
for the type of machine you have and so
we can really optimize and give you the
the the best product. So yeah,
>> interesting. I like what you said there
about the camera solutions as well as
the LAR solutions coming from uh from
Ster. I again want to draw a parallel
with the AV industry. Um that again is a
couple of years ahead of maybe the
robotics industry. A critical issue
there is sensor cost as well as sensor
size and the integration of the sensor
into an AV platform or into a robotic
platform. Are you seeing similar
requirements in the robotics industry
for smaller and more cost-effective
sensors?
>> Um, yeah, of course. I mean, people are
asking for this, but this the
performance is more important than the
cost and the size today. So, they want a
sensors that perform 24/7 that doesn't
stop that gives a you know precise depth
estimation u on the whole range. uh we
our customers do do sensor fusion. So
they have a lighter, they have different
cameras, 2D cameras, 3D cameras, they
have one you know uh ARM based computer
with a GPU and everything needs to work.
So we are seeing that we need to focus
on the system not only just the modules
today because every module can work you
know by itself but when you combine
eight or 10 cameras and and you want to
have a a high performance uh system this
this becomes much more challenging. So
we always have this approach of you know
making sure that everything works
together and uh yeah
>> and you mentioned it there already
actually but sensor and compute
integration is becoming more and more
important. What are you doing there at
stereo labs on that topic? I mean we
definitely work uh hand inhand with
Nvidia and and ARM uh our compute
especially for us because we we sell the
hardware but all our software tool is uh
on the host uh computer and and we
definitely uh work very closely with
Nvidia. So of course uh as I said it's a
system. So we we not only develop
cameras we think about the system that
the our customers are going to use and
we want to and the cost becomes uh
important here because the compute costs
are getting are increasing very fast. So
this is something that we always make
sure we we yeah we it's important to uh
to understand the cost that uh the
machine needs to have. It depends. If
you have a small robot that cost, you
know, you sell it for $1,000, of course,
you're not gonna, you know, you're going
to decide on different type of compute
and different types of sensor. If you
have a a larger uh machine, as you know,
we see at Dexterity, for example, there
they have different expectations. So, we
need to have this flexibility and
sensors and compute definitely work
together. Uh yeah, you can have one
without the other one. So, big
optimization here.
>> Thank you. Uh and John, we've spoken
about this and I think Cecil just
covered that, but you expect an
evolution in sensors for physical AI
applications. How do you see that
impacting compute requirements moving
forward at ARM?
>> Yeah, I think I'd echo a lot of what
[clears throat] Cecil said. Um you know,
if you think about where we are in the
the life cycle of very capable
autonomous, you know, humanoid quadriped
robots, we we're fairly fairly early on
in that life cycle. There's a lot of
exploration happening. I think as we
move more towards um commercial scale
out um we're undoubtedly going to see
cost reductions in some of those
sensitives
have liars on them today um and you know
they're fairly expensive components
right so as you go to more towards
commercial scale out you know we could
probably expect that you know lower cost
LAR sensors are going to come into play.
Um there will be scenarios where you
only have vision sensing. You know, you
have a fairly constrained environment,
maybe a factory floor that's well well
understood and well mapped and maybe
just vision sensing is is enough and you
don't you don't need a liar. Um but in
terms of you know um optimizations in
respect to compute, I think there's a
there's a tendency to think that as we
on this path to create more capable
autonomous robots, we need to throw more
compute at the problem. we need to throw
more advanced AI models at the problem.
Um, but the reality is these systems are
really constrained by two two critical
factors, power and thermals. And you
know on a humanoid robot you're limited
in terms of battery capacity and you're
limited by the amount of actual physical
cooling active cooling that you can that
that you can have and and and and mount
on onto the robot. So, you know, those
two things being the limiting factors
leads us to think that actually there's
a big piece of work to do in terms of
overall system optimization. I think
we've all kind of touched on touched on
the point in in different ways here, but
that system optimization, being able to
efficiently run AI models on a
constrained environment with battery and
power, you know, thermals taken into
account, I think is really the next big
thing. So it's taking that complete
sensor um to uh brain and and actuator
system and making that entire pathway
more efficient and being able to deploy
models in a very very efficient way uh
that that run very efficiently on that
on that main kind of NVIDIA platform
whatever the main the main brain of the
computer is.
>> Thank you. And it's interesting you
mentioned that we've seen a a wide array
of robotic form factors out there today
and you're fortunate enough to visit a
lot of robotics labs around the world.
What have you seen in terms of novel
designs to improve compute or improve
power efficiency?
>> Um yeah, I fortunately I do visit a lot
of robotics labs. I think one thing I
would say is that um there is a there is
a carpenter somewhere making a lot of
money out of building wooden staircases
that go to [laughter] lead to nowhere
deployed all over the robotics labs in
in Europe. Um on on a serious point I
think you know
there are you know certain design
choices to to to be made in terms of the
form factor of a robot you know there's
a lot of um you know focus on biped um
by bipedal humanoid robots but in a lot
of applications that probably may not be
may not be required you know depending
on the use case in the application it
may make sense to have you know a
humanoid form factor but on wheels um
that probably is a safer platform to be
around particularly around you know in
an environment with with with lots of
people around probably safer um but also
allows you the capability to maybe put
more compute into the base of that base
of that platform um or more battery
capacity into the base of that platform.
So I think there you know a lot of
exploration in terms of in in terms of
uh form factors going on. Um they
ultimately as we've said already
ultimately all of those things are going
to be driven by the specific use case of
the robot. We were talking about, you
know, a robot deployed in a hospital
application environment earlier.
Absolutely makes sense for that to be on
wheels and not a biped, right? Because
it's walking into oncology, you know,
children's oncology units and and it's,
you know, much much safer to have that
on a on a fixed wheelbase than than a
than as a biped. So, a lot of the the
form factor choices will be um will be
dependent on the end use case and
application for the robot, I think. And
we'll stay on the topic of form factors
and we'll speak to to Robert and Rob
over there about their form factors. You
touched on it earlier, your customers,
Robert, uh, FedEx in particular looking
for superhuman performance for their
deployments. What novel approaches have
you taken? You mentioned about the the
additional elbows, but can you share
more more on that topic?
>> Yeah, I'll again give a twofold answer
both from the compute perspective as
well as from the mechanical perspective.
uh when
you've got to move in tight spaces and
you want to be able to both compute
faster your motions as well as execute
them faster. Uh we've had to go through
a lot of optimization on robot shape and
robot strength. It's really like a a
trade-off. I liken it to like building a
rocket. you have to always carry your
fuel to the uh next stage. And you can
build a bigger rocket, but you'll have
to carry more fuel. And so it's a it's a
race to the bottom. And the similar
story goes for robotics as well. You
want a stronger robot, you want stronger
wrists, you'll have to carry those
motors at the end, your distal end of
your robot. And so your um your base
joints are going to have to be much
stronger or much heavier. And so there's
a delicate balance of how much strength
you need, how much dexterity you need,
and playing with that as well as
understanding from the manufacturer's
perspective. We work with Kawasaki for
example, what is possible, what isn't
possible. That creates a uh very unique
PTO optimal for us to be able to choose
the right shape and the right strength
for the robot. Um we generally uh look
for a little bit better than OSHA
requirements, right? OSHA only says you
can lift what 22 lbs or 25 lbs until you
get to two people that can lift double
that. And we want to be able to handle
at least two people's worth of tasks. We
don't need to do too much beyond that.
uh but we don't want to go too low as
well on in terms of uh compute though uh
again we're very power and thermal
constrained but we have so many imaging
sensors from RGB RGB and depth and LAR
and the data is very dense and it's tens
to hundreds of megapixels of data flying
in all at the same time. If you're going
to sequentially go through all of them
it is impossible to make a decision. The
problem with say neural networks and a
lot of things is you're spending your
brain power on all the data all the time
and maybe 90% of the data is not very
useful and so I've got to give a cue to
programming frameworks like CUDA and
whatnot to be able to really easily
ingest the data in parallel filter out
or create features from the important
aspects ignore the non-important aspects
so you can give your model a chance to
actually perform well without having to
waste your flops on absolutely
everything and getting the data from the
camera into the memory layout and that
is possible for that parallel computing
directly in one stage without any sort
of transformations and then programming
your compute to be able to use that
memory layout has been super important
to be able to handle the influx of all
of that data and make a decision really
fast. So really good programmability,
really good parallelism, really good
direct sensor to memory transfer has
been completely revolutionary for us. Uh
and then of course apply the right
mechanical design and you can build a
very superhuman robot in both decision-m
speed as well as actual execution speed.
>> Thank you for that. And there's one
thing I want to hone in in on there in
particular and I want to ask the
question to you Rob because we spoke
about it earlier and that question is
regard to actuators. Actuators play a
key pole key role in robotic movement
acting like the muscles of humans
essentially. What is the situation with
actuators right now and are they a
commodity?
>> Up to a certain level they are. Um, if
you look at some of the open source
projects we did, um, they're just using
off-the-shelf actuators. There's
definitely a gradient though. And if you
want to push up to higher performance,
you can't just go and buy those. You
can't order those online. Going back to
the general point of talking about now
though, I for me what I'm thinking as
you're talking about these things is
that there's a tension between the
specialization and the generalization.
It's always been sensible to make
specialized machines because you can
home them and you can ignore data you
don't need and you can focus them on the
task at hand. But the kind of vision
we're talking about where you can
elevate a society through a mass
generalization of automation, can that
be achieved [clears throat] through a
series of specializations or do we have
to fundamentally move towards a
technology we don't yet have? And I as
everyone's talking it makes me wonder if
if we just keep sequentially making more
and more specialized machines surely
that's heading away [clears throat] from
generalization.
Um so that's the kind of tension I think
we need to address. It it it makes sense
if you want to do a certain thing you
design it a certain way you can make it
superhuman but this machine which can do
all of these things that we want so that
you can really alleviate lots of
different tasks and you can swap them
into lots of different roles. Um, I
wonder if we can get uh the way we're
presently going.
>> Exactly. And that's something Robert and
I discussed actually that generalist
robots I think we're still very far away
from, but robots for specific tasks is
possible and are being deployed across
the US and across Europe. Now, um, I
want to touch on some of the key areas
that maybe humanoid robots in particular
lack on. And this was something Rob, you
and I discussed. Rodney Brooks, who's
probably developed more humanoid robots
than than anyone else in the world. He
believes that deployable dexterity, so
dextrous man manipulation hands are are
pathetic. His words, not mine. Um, but
is that another example of of hardware,
you know, being crude in comparison to
to what we are capable of as humans?
>> Yes, I suspect it probably is. Um, all
of the problems are magnified when you
try and make them into hands. It's uh
it's smaller, it's more compact, the
thermal gets harder, the power gets
harder. Um and again, if you look at it
from a civilizational level, our
civilization was was literally built by
hands. So, if we're going to enable this
next era, then we have to solve this
problem. Um the physics ends up that you
either have to is it easier to get rid
of heat or is it easier to transmit
mechanical power? Um both have their
their their issues particularly in
maintenance for tension driven systems.
But Rodney talks about deeper problems
that we don't have even a language to
describe what it means to be dextrous.
We can't describe tasks. We can't
therefore talk coherently about the data
we need. We can't really even describe
the problem yet. So that's where he's
coming from. But he's quite a
pessimistic fellow. Um if you've
[clears throat] ever met him,
I'm more optimistic. Um but maybe
[snorts] I'm just naive. I I like to
think that if we have enough uh
innovation and we have enough
collaboration that these techniques can
be applied and that something will
emerge from it which is more than we are
expecting. So we're just going to keep
pushing it along and hopefully we can do
it faster than he thinks we can.
Certainly that's what we're going to do.
Um but that's partly because I enjoy
designing hands. So we we just keep
designing and building them and we keep
applying techniques. Um, but you can
look at how LLM's emerged that it was it
was laughable even a few years ago to
think that we could do what we can do
now with AI. It was pipe pipe dream and
then all of a sudden it pops up and
suddenly we're taking these things very
seriously and we're designing
medicines and solving protein problems
and we can do real things with them. Um
[clears throat] so things can emerge if
we have this collaborative system. If we
have uh a lot of people working together
on these on these hard problems as
hardware prices continue to come down we
get some aspects of uh commodification.
We get um shared uh benchmarks then I'm
hopeful that we will we will get there
faster than he thinks.
>> Thank you. Thank you for sharing that.
And I'm conscious on time. We're running
towards the end, but I think to
summarize this across sensing, across
advanced compute, across certain key
robotic building blocks, hardware is
still not yet a commodity. And I think
the old refrain is true. Hardware is
hard, but hardware and software are
still constrained and defined by each
other. And we really need to champion
the next generation of hardware builders
because they will play an integral part
in enabling the safe and mass deployment
of physical AI systems. Um, thank you
for joining us today. Uh, it's been a
pleasure to host this panel. Uh, and
enjoy the rest of Machina. Thank you.